[Musique]
quand on a ouvert on a ouvert les potins
le dépôt de journaux
[Musique]
et c'est vrai que du coup on vit très
vite les gens ont pris l'habitude en
fait de venir chercher du coup le pain
avec le petit croissant le café le matin
pour discuter autour du cou d'un petit
café tous ensemble et puis bah du coup
le dia le journal qui va qui arrivait
que c'était un machin dont tout le monde
prend sa pause effet
qu'est ce qui te faut
croissants café le bar a fêté sa
première bougie du coup le 1er juillet
de cette année donc c'est vrai qu'on est
assez fier on était assez assez content
du tout d'abord je tenir un an surtout
dans ce contexte de qu'on a actuellement
mais mais ouais on était assez fier du
coup je résultats et à devoir du coup
qu'on a vu qu'on avait réussi le pari en
fait c'était chaud on est complètement
sur un équilibre en fait sont
au dessus en fait de ce qu'on attendait
vous pensez pas à voir autant de monde
on pensait pas en fait que ça ne
marcherait aussi bien mais on voulait en
fait sur moi c'était mon objectif
premier était de redonner en fait
quelque chose ouvert à l'année à
gargilesse c'est vrai que du coup on
travaille beaucoup de connivence en fait
du coup avec les collègues avec les gens
du cou qui tiennent aussi beaucoup des
commerces en fête dans dans notre
commune pac
[Musique]
ravoir j'étais coiffeuse en fait j'ai
fait du coup 14e coiffure j'ai travaillé
en banlieue parisienne paris j'ai fait
du coup sur vannes marseille et puis
après en fait je suis arrivé ici si vous
changez de métier en le contactant
coiffure on est beaucoup en fait du coup
dans le toucher au final touch en fait
les gens et c'est vrai que du coup dans
le bar on a contacté complètement
différent en fait avec les gens on n'a
pas le physique mais on a en fait du
coup l'oral et on partage beaucoup plus
au final même pas ce que ça aille dans
un salon de coiffure en fait au final
les gens sont là pour se détendre alors
que dans un bar en fait les gens sont là
pour avoir du contexte social en fait du
coup le contact est pas du tout le monde
dans cette chaleur tout ça c'est pour
nous hop faut que je te donne ça
tac com d'art postal et tiens je vais
comme ça mais du coup oui donc beaucoup
trop
voilà ça crée des conversations de
l'affectif en soit aussi tout simplement
parce que quand on voit les gens de tous
les jours que l'on partage leurs
problèmes leurs soucis qu'ils arrivent
le matin avec du coup un petit un petit
chagrin petit machin que bah du coup on
est là pour les écouter pour leur parler
pour les conseillers aussi des fois ça
nous arrive c'est vrai que du coup le
contacter ou même en fait on fait
partie de la famine tout simple
may
[Musique]
cry
c'est tellement un village familial au
final que
je le conçois pas comme être patronne en
fait j'ai l'impression d'être plus du
coup dans un jour et c'est vrai que
c'est je le prends beaucoup comme ça
beaucoup à la rigolade on s'amuse
beaucoup et c'est ce qui concerne cette
finale
[Musique]